en el frente religioso de ucrania los
ortodoxos también se oponen al
presidente de rusia para este sacerdote
del bid la guerra con ucrania es una
repetición moderna de la historia
bíblica de caín y abel su crema
el presidente de rusia es el caín de hoy
en día que no tuvo miedo de oponerse a
su hermano abel y por envidia por
algunos de sus intereses muy
probablemente por orgullo se opuso a
toda ucrania y al pueblo ucraniano
el monasterio ortodoxo del pib que pide
que se rompan lazos con la iglesia rusa
tras la invasión de ucrania se ha
reconvertido por la guerra ahora el
edificio es un depósito de ayuda
humanitaria refugio para aquellos que
huyen de los bombardeos rusos a los que
se les proporciona comida y cobijo
nos trasladamos después de que empezaran
los bombardeos mientras estábamos en
kiev para ser sincera no quiero dejar mi
país porque entiendo que después de la
guerra habrá que restaurarlo podemos
trabajar
como la iglesia ortodoxa tiene un gran
peso en ucrania y tras más de 300 años
de tutela rusa el país estableció una
iglesia propia a finales de 2018
después de que comenzara la guerra en
ucrania el monasterio ha estado llevando
a cabo servicios sociales en primer
lugar ayudando a los vecinos a los niños
a los que lo necesitan
y a pesar de haber recibido amenazas el
centro ortodoxo está decidido a ayudar a
los ucranianos víctimas de este
conflicto armado